[Música]
empezamos nuestro segmento especial de
aquí a américa camino a la casa blanca
el espacio para revisar los temas clave
de esta contienda entre el presidente de
donaldson y el candidato demócrata joe
bayrén de cara a las elecciones del 3 de
noviembre hoy vamos a hablar del cobi 19
con más de 6 millones y medio de casos
confirmados y casi 200.000 muertes eeuu
es el país más afectado del mundo por lo
que desde luego la crisis sin
precedentes marca la campaña
presidencial
las medidas de confinamiento causaron
inmensos estragos en la economía y según
la reserva federal habrá una contracción
del 3 7% de este año por lo que se ha
hecho una prioridad para trump el
hallazgo de la vacuna perfilándola como
la solución definitiva el jueves el
mandatario insistió en que la inyección
iba a estar lista en octubre en
contradicción al centro para el control
de enfermedades
y debido a las críticas por negar los
hechos científicos el mandatario tuvo
que matizar sus declaraciones el viernes
y dijo que la distribución masiva de la
vacuna llegaría en ávila
habremos fabricado al menos 100 millones
de dosis de vacunas antes de fin de año
y probablemente muchas más cientos de
millones de dosis estarán disponibles
cada mes y esperamos tener suficientes
vacunas para todos los estadounidenses
en abril sin esperar que vamos a hablar
en miami con nuestro corresponsal
anthony welsch anthony la vacuna se está
presentando como el elixir que
solucionaría la crisis entienden los
electores estadounidenses que el acceso
a la vacuna no depende de quien esté en
la oficina oval
así que muy buenas tardes pues lo cierto
es que no se sabe si la gente es
consciente de que esa decisión para
lanzar la vacuna no depende de la
administración de turno que ocupa la
casa blanca sino que es un trabajo
reservado a los científicos el mismo
presidente tal y como lo habíamos
escuchado ha dicho que a mediados de
abril está previsto que todos los
estadounidenses que lo requieran podrán
acceder a la vacuna una afirmación que
contrasta con lo que dice la
administración de alimentos y fármacos
la fed y los centros para el control y
prevención de enfermedades que dicen que
hay que tomarse ese tipo de afirmaciones
con muchísima más cautela y precaución
porque hay que hacer muchísimos más
ensayos para asegurar la efectividad de
estas dosis y en este caso qué
importancia tiene la el apoyo de la
comunidad científica al joe valdez
y de hecho cada vez hay más voces
críticas de expertos médicos científicos
que están trabajando en los laboratorios
aquí en eeuu recordemos que hay dos
laboratorios que están trabajando por
esta vacuna aquí en el país
norteamericano por un lado está a facer
y modernas que están pidiendo a la
administración al gobierno
norteamericano que pues moderen bastante
más esas palabras porque dicen que se
está convirtiendo en un tema de campaña
la cuestión de la vacuna y por supuesto
donald tran no quiere dar su brazo a
torcer siempre que puede estar hablando
de ese posible el lanzamiento cuanto
antes de la vacuna de la cob y de 19 él
sabe que es un tema importante y que en
eso también está su victoria o no las
próximas elecciones y algo similar ha
sucedido con el uso de la mascarilla los
republicanos por un lado han sido un
poco más reacios el presidente donald
trump no lo vimos tanto usando
mascarillas como joe biden
por qué
si de hecho en los últimos meses a raíz
de la pandemia y cuando se habían
cancelado la mayoría de eventos
políticos hemos visto una gran
diferencia entre los demócratas y los
republicanos son más allá de la
ideología mientras que el equipo de joe
biden canceló todos los eventos de la
convención nacional demócrata y lo hice
todo a través de internet
donald trump y el partidor democrática
no quiso ir adelante de hecho la mayoría
de los discursos se realizaron en
washington y precisamente ese gran
evento de final de la convención en
republicana desde la casa blanca más de
1000 personas se congregaron sin
respetar a las medidas del
distanciamiento social ni tampoco la
mascarilla eso fue algo también muy
criticado por los cdc
gracias a nuestro corresponsal en miami
anthony welsch y por su intervención en
este segmento especial de aquí a américa
camino a la casa blanca y a ustedes
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas cuídense mucho del coronavirus
y sigan viendo france24
[Música]